New York Times chief White House
correspondent that's Peter Baker has
covered every administration since
President Bill Clinton his new book is
Obama the call of history Peter Baker
has served as Moscow bureau chief for
The Washington Post he joins us from
Washington Peter good morning good
morning how are you I'm okay listen we
saw a handshake we saw a smile they're
describing this as the most anticipated
meeting of the summit what are you
looking for what are you thinking is you
know they say Vladimir Putin is very
well trained President Trump they say is
going in with no agenda what are you
looking for yeah I know that's exactly
right as major put it that's a lot to
pack into just a half an hour with
translation and the trick is is a
charming master the president's national
security adviser said he doesn't the
president doesn't have a specific agenda
you can be sure that Vladimir Putin does
and when he starts talking he can get
you could last the entire half hour
President Putin has a way in these
meetings have sort of dominating the
conversation lecturing sometimes
monologuing filibustering and at least
it see how these two people who circled
around each other now for so many months
with so many other fraud issues Syria
Ukraine this investigation here in the
United States hovering over them it'll
be interesting to see how they manage to
present both body language and actual
substance how do you think the Kremlin
will exploit this advantage of this
meeting well look just the very fact of
it is what the Kremlin wants they want
President Putin on the world stage as
the leader to meet the leader who's
important at the center of everything
member just two years ago three years
ago Putin was isolated after the
intervention in Ukraine and the
annexation of Crimea he he was thrown
out of the g8 was now the g7 he was left
on the sidelines of a g20 nobody really
wanted to talk to him now he's the man
in the middle that's exactly what the
Kremlin wants they want Russia to be the
central player and how important is it
for president trumping the United States
to show strength given Russia's position
as you know I mean Russia and China
denying that North Korea even launched
an ICBM yeah this they have this come
from such different worldviews Russia
reality is different than the reality
for the rest of the world and they will
you know take advantage of that but
you're right I think that this is kind
of a test of manhood
these leaders both President Trump and
President Putin they they project
masculinity they are tough men they
value toughness in each other one of the
things I think we found with President
Obama is that is that President Putin
took his measure decided he was not a
particularly strong leader that may or
may not have been fair but that was
president Putin's conclusion
president Trump values more than
anything I think sort of a you know
chest thrusts out kind of relationship
with with other leaders and oh good to
see how these two sort of go mano-a-mano
if they do so Peter might there be less
chest thrusting then and in a potential
meeting with Xi Jinping and and and is
there ground to to come together on when
it comes to North Korea the US and China
yeah that that meeting is a different
kind of meeting right president Trump
made friends with Xi Jinping and
mar-a-lago he professed again and again
what a good guy
the Chinese president was because he was
hoping he would help pressure North
Korea to stop it's sort of provocative
missile tests and so far that hasn't
worked and you've seen now president
Trump a couple times on Twitter saying
well we should you know we tried it
didn't work now we'll see what happens
the real test is if America is going to
apply pressure on North Korea other than
military action then it's going to have
to actually take on some of these
Chinese entities that are facilitating
North Korea that's going to be a real
test and do you get any sense from your
reporting that that is on the agenda by
the Trump administration well I think it
is you saw even just a couple weeks ago
they they sanctioned a Chinese bank
that's been doing business with North
Korea that's really the first time that
it happened on a big level these banks
are you know the real conduit for North
Korean money in and out of the country
America has been reluctant to go after
Chinese entities in any real way up till
now because we have a pretty important
relationship with China as well but
that's the that's the economic lever
that's out there if President Trump
chooses to use it a lot of speculation
Peter president Trump will ask about the
Russian election meddling in the u.s.
campaign should he will he was a lot of
expectation that he should anyway you'll
certainly hear it from Democrats if he
doesn't you know he said just yesterday
that he said he cast doubt once again on
whether it really happened he I think it
was Russia I think it could have been
other places nobody knows for sure
remember the intelligence agencies got
Iraq wrong and
really Obama's have done something about
it anyway he is it a sign of weakness if
he doesn't Peter I think I think Putin
would take it that way certainly
certainly and certainly so with the
Democrats here at home that in fact to
allow Russia to do what it did in last
year's election without confronting
Vladimir Putin about it face to face
would be a rather striking decision on
the president Trump's part right Peter
Baker we're all watching we thank you
very much for joining us this morning
thanks very much
really appreciate it